foreign
[Music]
not even a mouse
by the chimney with care in hopes that
Saint Nicholas soon would be there
who are you
I'm Santa Claus
it was different out there all those
kids turned into adults they stopped
believing and one was magic
so for the good of Christmas I'm
retiring wow I didn't even know you
could do that I think we've seen with
the rest of the world's like as normal
people I'm making a list of things I
want to do like meet a crossing guard
wow
wow sand already warned you this is what
I look like here it's it's Dad me
you don't have a funny Cheeto put cocoa
in it instead of coffee put a little
peppermint in there if you have to chop
up some cookies and um sprinkles that's
not Santa
my job is hard enough
for the first time I'm going to spend
Christmas with my family
new Santa is destroying Christmas spirit
when the last of the light goes out it
could be the end of Christmas I retire
too soon I hired the wrong guy I've got
to go back to the North Pole
elves are disappearing those are
disappearing you should have led with
that we're going
[Music]
are you seeing this
Christmas is in trouble let's go now
we're getting somewhere oh
[Music]